Candace Owens is the host of the Candace
Owens podcast and she has her own ideas
for what Stanford might ban on his
banned word list it's great to see you
tonight Candace thanks for coming on
both of us of course went to Stanford we
met in the computer science department
there and so for us this is personal
what would you suggest that they banned
trying to get banned I'm trying to abide
but easier if you're a student at
Stanford if you just kept your mouth
mouth shut it just seems like a walking
Minefield which is ridiculous but I
think if we can't you know we got to
join him we should ban some more words I
would say we should ban intelligence
obviously because it's an ableist turn
they had a whole section for ableism
right and of course intelligence would
be ableism it doesn't allow people who
don't have thinking brains to be able to
join in and clearly people that created
this list do not have thinking brains
and what people should be thinking when
they see things like this is that
college campuses have become a criminal
Enterprise kids are taking out hundreds
and thousands of dollars in loans to
attend these universities to be told
essentially that they can't speak and
met everything that they do is wrong I'm
not sure at what benefit it is for
parents to send their children to
University anymore when they come back
and they don't even know anything about
their own genders they come back dumber
than when you send them right because
they they see everything as a buzzword
everything as a trigger and in the end
they end up as non-productive human
beings in society that also have
hundreds and thousands of student loans
of student loan debt and nothing that
they're able to do because nobody wants
to hire these people these people that
are just sensitive crybabies what they
end up becoming are government
dependents angry professors they go back
into the ecosystem that taught them the
nonsense in the first place I mean this
list is so laughable but you shouldn't
laugh because this is coming from
Stanford University Stanford Harvard
Yale yes all these pretentious
universities supposed to be the best the
smartest the cream of the crop is so I'm
sure we're not allowed to say that by
the way are supposed to be attending
these University campuses and this is
what they come up with astounding Tucker
but it's also a cover for them so you
can't use the term beaded at horse
because it's violence against animals as
someone who actually loves animals I
would be interested to know how many
dogs cats and monkeys have been tortured
to death over the years at Stanford
because they got some government grant
to do it not to Advanced science but
simply because they got paid to torture
those animals to death you think they'll
answer that question
no I think what you're going to be
careful here because that could be
against the religion of fauchism and you
want to be very careful not to be
anti-fouchy anywhere because God forbid
you question any of his morals any of
the experience that they've done on
animals or the experimentation that they
did on human beings and you will land
yourself on the wrong side of Stanford
University so I'm I'm not as Brave as
you are Tucker I wouldn't dare speak
again against Dr fauci I would take a
beagle over fauci any day of the week
Kenneth Owens great to see you tonight
thank you so much subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight